cafe perio is in berlin's schoenberg
district it's it's in korea's favorite
spot in the german capital
here the brazilian singer feels right at
home
veryu is a wonderful cafe i was here for
the first time first time in 1994
was my first uh european tour and i i
sang a lot in germany and in berlin also
i don't remember the venue exactly but i
never forget the cafe because this is
something very very
important i think there is a kind of
shelter
that's incorrect has lived in berlin
since 2007.
he grew up in sao paulo in brazil where
his family still lives including his
grandmother mother and his siblings
despite his homesickness he's happy
living in the german capital
when you come from sao paulo from brazil
you are you need to be always aware
because it's really dangerous but in
berlin you can have the life quality of
living in a small city with the quality
of a big city culture
and everything so
i feel home and i feel safe that was
that it's
everything i dream one day
the video for his new song has already
hit the web
the project is called car men electrical
i'm 47 now but i was always clubber i i
have my own club in brazil that that can
imagine i really um
i come from the the clubs i
love dance music electronic music but i
always also
start singing
baroque music classical music so
in this project i can mix both in the
way i
like is a counter tenor with a vocal
range of four octaves
since the early 90s he's made a name for
himself both in brazil and europe with
his vocal acrobatics
he's known as the woman's voice
his 2005 album contra tenna was
nominated for a latin grammy
the challenge is how to touch people
there is the moment of course the moment
wow it's high it's low but must be a
time that you feel only exhibition is
not enough
corridors father always hoped his son
would make it big on the football pitch
my father i have three sisters when and
when i came
he
he
chose edson to make a tribute to pele
the football player original's name
original name is ed
so he had a hope that i could play
football and everything
but
very soon he realized that it will be it
will not happen
like many brazilians edson correiro is
critical of the world cup we have so
many some
many priorities so many things that
should be done in the country that you
shouldn't make a
do a kind of makeup in the country to
say oh everything
is beautiful and good because
it's so welcome world cup i think it's
really really
sad to see
edson
splits his time between brazil and
germany but for now he's staying in the
german capital to work on his various
projects
they have a lot more priority in his
life than football